Hey, I'm Jad I boom rod, this is radio lab today.
Eight experiments and translation
last from number three. They called it shell shock.
[inaudible] discovered the shale, the truck. Now you try
this one, Robert Krulwich and our producers are when wheeler talked to, right?
Or Adam Gopnik about George Carlin. And why is George Carlin mentioned?
Oh because Carlin is the wonderful sort of folk philosopher of language.
You're talking about the comedian. Comedian, yeah. And this next thing,
this next thing is about the English language.
It's about little expressions we use.
We all say in the little sayings and expressions that we use all the time.
Moses is one of his great subjects,
really seemed to examine these expressions and all the more interesting cause he
was, he didn't even have a high school education, you know,
so it was not something that he got from schooling and one of God,
Nick's favorite Carlin roofs. And I really liked this one too.
It's about how Carlin hated euphemisms. I don't like words that hide the truth.
I don't like words that conceal reality. I don't like euphemisms.
And American English is loaded with euphemisms cause Americans have a lot of
trouble dealing with reality. And Carlin was wonderful about things like that.
What about books as he called her? We have no more old people in this country.
No more old people.
We shipped them all away and we brought in these senior citizens.
Isn't that a tip? And he was unsympathetic.
The reason we use the euphemism I've just been through,
my father in law died like four months ago and we went through the same horrible
business that we all go through in an intensive care ward where the doctors and
nurse practitioners have a language that they've been taught.
We just want your father to be comfortable. He's gravely ill, he's gravely ill,
means he's dying, right?
And we want him to be comfortable means can we give him enough drugs so the hill
pass out before he dies and so on.
And so it's certainly true that euphemism can be a repellent thing,
but no one is fooled.
What we're mocking is the absurdity of the effort to disguise something that you
cannot disguise.
But Carlin's real point was that it it like Dole's our reactions to it that
actually has like a can have a negative effect and it gets worse with every
generation. And he has this whole bit,
it's about shellshock becoming PTSD. No, he goes, no, he goes,
it's in four different things. In the first world war,
that condition was called shell shock. They used to call it shell shot. Simple,
honest, direct language, two syllables, shell shock.
And then it became battle fatigue, battle fatigue.
Four syllables now takes a little longer to say it doesn't seem to hurt as much.
And then after it became battlefield t, then it became operational exhaustion.
Hey, we're up to eight syllables now.
Then it became post traumatic shock disorder, still eight syllables,
but we've added a hyphen and then it became PTSD,
post traumatic stress disorder.
The pain is completely buried under jargon.
This was the Orwell notion that you could erase sensitivities if you blanded out
the word. So have you stopped saying no? Yeah, we just tortured the guy.
If you say some force of interrogation or enhanced interrogation,
that makes a big difference.
And part of what Carl and his saying is that like now that as PTSD we are not
having the appropriate reaction to it. I mean it's Shell Shock Betcha.
If we'd still been calling us shell shock,
some of those Vietnam veterans might've gotten the attention they needed at the
time.
Okay,
but now you're putting your finger on the,
this is where the rubber meets the road.
Does the use of euphemism,
does that really rob us of some understanding and Adam Gopnik surprisingly says
maybe not the truth, it's just the opposite.
We actually have more of an apparatus to help people with PTSD than they did in
1915 to help guys with shell shock.
The reason the word gets more abstract is be exactly because you have a much
more complicated and abstract system of support.
It's not because the reason it's called PTSD is because it's a more complex in
n. Yes. Because think about what that evolution says. The initial thing was, oh,
these guys are being driven crazy because the shells are exploding all around.
On the western front. Gopnik says, the thinking was, you know, it was temporary.
The shell goes off, it explodes in a moment.
They have a moment of shock and they need a moment of rest and then they can go
back in, but by World War II we are thinking that's not quite right.
It's not just shells exploding, right? It's the whole experience of battle.
It's all the shooting and the death and the fear, so it becomes battle fatigue.
You're trying to generalize it. You're trying to make it richer as the content.
It also becomes a fatigue versus shock. There's less violence in this, right,
because,
because you're looking at guys who may not exhibit the symptoms of shock
necessarily, but over time it becomes impossible for them to go on.
There's a wonderful film from World War II called let there be light.
These are the casual days at the skirt troubled in mind named who I damaged
emotionally about guys with what they were then calling battle fatigue and the
reason they were calling it that was because you didn't necessarily see it right
away. Then around Vietnam he says,
we realized you don't just see this on the battlefield.
You see it with guys who aren't necessarily directly involved in battle. Right?
And so the question became, what's the source of it? It's you say, well,
it's nervous exhaustion.
You say the human nervous system can only take it for so long and then
everybody's nervous system shuts down. Hence the term operational exhaustion.
Oh, that's example. Again, when you're trying to enrich it,
you're saying the guys aren't cowards and not in a state of shock.
They are behaving the way all human beings do and then you get more concerned
about them and you say, the real problem isn't there,
just their experience on the battlefield.
The problem is is that they are in a constant state of disorder because it
lingers on long after you think it's over.
You can't just get these guys into a hospital for six months and think they're
going to be better. They are permanently you.
They have post traumatic shock and then once you have a, uh,
whole apparatus to deal with it, then you becomes PTSD.
My point is just that it's perfectly possible that the language of euphemism
grows and becomes more abstract as actually as people actually are becoming more
empathetic to the people who suffer from it. Saren do you buy, I mean, he's,
he's easily turned Carlin on his head and he's made these blander and three
words, enrichments I have, I mean,
my only move would be to hit play on Carlin. Poor people used to live in slums.
Now the economically disadvantaged occupied substandard housing in the inner
cities
there, Bro. Yeah, Bro. They don't have it yet.
Negative cash flow position
and blow.